yeah what's the big message here about
the grind of like a year first year
cockroaches getting booed off stage
right to you know fifth year
age 25 keep in mind right books
traveling the world podcast what's the
the underlying message there well it's
funny because i talk a lot on my show
and in my next book actually about you
know in a lot of ways the american dream
is dead for a lot of people just with
finances and things like that but there
is still so much opportunity in america
that there isn't anywhere else and that
if you have something that you want to
do you can do it absolutely but most
young people would rather go spend their
money on avocado toast and things that
that they can't afford you know i think
it's like 50 of people can't even afford
a 500 bill if something were to happen
to them that's terrible yeah that's
happening and it's because a lot of
people are just very bad with their
money every all the money that i made
for my first book all the money that i
made for my speeches
i didn't spend any of it you know
investing things yeah i think that's
another thing that's like a big problem
to like financial like understanding how
to control your finances that's a huge
problem like you just don't need it like
you don't need to spend that money you
will be so much happier well as we say
save that money well right now
um so all right ladies go ahead go ahead
taylor so for one i would say
like the real pandemic and i'm being
tongue-in-cheek here is the inability
for the american people to understand
money we do not understand it and so i
took initiative early on right after i
graduated college to learn money rich
dad poor dad that book changed my life
but
i agree pursuing passion but i also
think you have to do it smart i'm so
glad it worked out for some people but
like the fact that i'm at valuetainment
it's a dream come true but i paid off
all my debt paid off my car paid off my
college worked saved money invest the
money before i just made that leap so
when i came here i don't have to stress
about money because i'm in sales and i'm
like learning that rich dad poor dad
would tell you the opposite
it'd be like that's more like a dave
ramsey approach yeah but i i guess you
don't have to pay all your debt but when
i'm making this move so i moved to
illinois and i'm originally from
michigan now i moved to florida i was
still pursuing passion i was making
videos on my my you know in my living
room by myself like i was still doing
that i was trying to sell artwork
but i was still doing it in a
responsible way i love going after
passion but sometimes it's not going to
work out in the stress of having to
worry about money when you're away from
friends and family it's a lot on people
so i think doing it in an intelligent
way and learning about money how to save
budget and that would be what i would
say for sure go ahead fosh what are your
thoughts on all this
foster's whole time is like yes all
right go ahead
i like listening to people and
understanding their like viewpoints and
stuff um what's the question exactly
well you know his grind so you do real
estate and you're an entrepreneur
because you're also like a hot thing on
instagram yes so what's your career path
so my career path now is like i'm going
more into like real estate so my idea so
first of all i i went to college i
actually finished not that that's like
super important
me too she said you actually yeah she's
looking ready
so i have like my business degree and um
social media marketing um so i finished
that
and i feel like
i didn't really i learned but like it
was definitely eye opener being around
different people and understanding
different
um people's viewpoints in life and
understanding them
so that happened um my career path now
that i'm going towards is real estate
owning
um cells for sure but like what's really
important to me is building a brand
around myself so that way i have that
brand no matter what and then i can also
i can continue leveraging off of that
for years and years and years to come
that's what i'm always thinking about
i'm thinking about the future i'm like
how can i
you know make money off of this
continuously so me building myself as a
brand
i think
help is helping me a lot with that for
me i just and a lot in so much of what i
did
i never really cared if i made that much
money you know i still don't really care
that much about the money i want to be
able to live a comfortable life for sure
and have a great home and be able to
provide for my children yeah absolutely
but i just never really cared about
being rich or anything like that i'm
more just i do a lot of it just because
of the passion i understand that's
probably not good advice for people no i
like that because you want to do what
you're passionate my my only thing to
some people is
especially when they're very impulsive
and they just go and do it and it's like
okay maybe they were meant to do that
but the way they went about it
didn't and then it didn't work out and
honestly like
like you can say follow your passion but
like i feel like a lot of people aren't
realistic like i really feel like that's
a problem
i think it's a really good point because
we talk about so thank you
thank you we're talking about chasing
money or following your passions
but foster's interjected well let's all
be realistic about this please yes okay
i'm not saying you can't follow your
dreams but like pat talked about
look
pat would love to be able to jump 46
inches like lebron and dunk on people's
heads he's like i just can't jump so
good right you know or he wants to sing
like whitney houston he's like i have a
horrible voice so there needs to be some
realism right uh in both your self-aware
self-awareness self-awareness maybe you
make money and you're doing what you're
passionate on the side and until those
things
and that's exactly what happened here is
that i
i
followed my passions for many years
awesome you know nightlife fun party
guys stand up comedy entertainment
broke as [ __ ]
got out of that went into the financial
career did that for 10 years made a
bunch of money circled back to all that
were you passionate about the financial
career i was passionate about how much
money i'm making that oh that's what
keeps me going i don't wake up every day
being like investments insurers let's do
this thing but
it is a i i'm passionate about the
lifestyle allows me to do and allows me
to do this exactly and not have to worry
about my bills
[Music]